monsieur couillard vous êtes le premier
ministre du québec
vous êtes un homme responsable s'il te
plaît agissez en variolique ce chauffeur
de taxi du québec ont interpellé
bruyamment le premier ministre philippe
couillard ce matin des centaines d'entre
eux ont manifesté à montréal mais aussi
à québec et ailleurs dans la province
demande au gouvernement d'agir
immédiatement pour forcer la compagnie
iber qui offrent du service de
covoiturage à se conformer à la loi
chauffeur de taxi exige aussi une
rencontre avec le premier ministre lui
mène vers donc il s'attire les foudres
des compagnies de taxi d'ici et
d'ailleurs
frédéric donc hubert est très présent
sur les cinq continents il faut pas se
leurrer ce n'est pas une petite
entreprise non céline hubert n'est
vraiment peu d'entreprises sont
lendemain alors avec leurs différentes
formules dont cube erich huber xl hubert
pop fine il y en a plein ces deux
entreprises qui était fondée en 2009 en
fait en californie à san francisco
vous l'avez dit c'est une entreprise qui
est quand même sur les cinq continents
et à 58 pays 250 à 300 villes c'est un
chiffre qui fluctuent en fait quasiment
de semaine en semaine parce qu'il ya
toujours des recours devant les
tribunaux pour essayer de les bloquer
hubert est également présent dans 46
états américains alors c'est quand même
une grosse valeur potentielle à peu près
51 millions de doll 51 milliards de
dollars sur papier jeudi sur papier
parce qu'en fait comme ce n'est pas
inactive une compagnie qui est coté en
bourse pour l'instant c'est à ces
chiffres qu'il faut se fier et même
microsoft et google ont mis de l'argent
là-dedans donc c'est clair que c'est
quand même assez groupe
et quand on parle du problème du berce
pas juste à montréal évidemment il y en
a partout au canada à commencer par
vancouver où effectivement fait à
vancouver hubert et essayer de rentrer
par deux fois sur le marché d'abord en
2012 tout de suite la commission des
transports de la région s'est réveillé
en disant non vous n'avez aucun accès
vous devez payer des permis en 2014 ils
ont réessayé encore une fois sans succès
donc pour l'instant c'est vraiment banni
de vancouver edmonton la ville de
moncton s'est rendu jusque devant les
tribunaux pour stopper la croissance
d'hubert sans succès alors pour
l'instant on travaille à mettre des
réglementations pour mettre de plus en
plus de bâtons dans les roues du bain
et puis enfin à toronto en ontario en
fait là c'est toujours présents sauf
qu'il ya un recours collectif de 400
millions de dollars qui étaient déposées
contre hubert par l'industrie du taxi et
des limousines et ailleurs dans le monde
il est partout il ya des endroits où on
interdit carrément oui en fait des
interdictions totales ou partielles
c'est le cas par exemple de la thaïlande
y est également l'état du nevada
interdiction partielle aux pays-bas en
allemagne à bruxelles en belgique et
certaines villes d'australie
et puis il ya aussi des endroits où ils
les opérations étaient suspendues par
exemple c'est le cas de la corée du sud
de l'espagne et de six villes
américaines mais aussi de la france et
là c'est un cas particulier parce que là
c'est hubert qui a décidé de se retirer
momentanément osmani c'est incroyable
beaucoup de violence il craignait
beaucoup pour la sécurité des chauffeurs
donc là pour l'instant ils se sont
retirés mais ils vont probablement
revenir parce que gilbert a vraiment les
reins fort pour se permettre ça merci
beaucoup